from the studio that's finally running
out of young adult franchises comes the
fourth film in The Hunger Games trilogy
that confirms once and for all
Catching Fire will be remembered as the
good Hunger Games movie The Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 2 they've been building
to the conclusion of The Hunger Games
franchise since 2012
now after two child murder Super Bowls
and one unnecessary feature-length
prologue strap in for the long-awaited
finale where Katniss Everdeen completes
her epic revenge quest to murder
President Snow by not murdering
President Snow wait are you kidding me
they just calmly talk in a rose garden
you call that a satisfying conclusion
that's like Kill Bill if they never
killed bill the all-out war you've been
waiting for since the first Hunger Games
is finally here and you don't get to see
any of it instead gear up for a joyless
parade of less exciting stuff like war
boring districts discussions but I'm not
sure that anyone outside of - knows what
we've been up against we were under
attack and district 8 district 12
district 2 were standing together with
13 districts filming viral videos hold
it Pollux tighter okay all new red
shirts on lieutenant Jackson
he's the league sisters this is second
lieutenant Mitchell this is corporal
homes casually walking through war zones
and hanging out with tiger people Tigers
thank you for everything everything hang
on a second tiger people really since
one of their tiger people in this world
don't tell me they're in the book you
put people that so doesn't count you
rolled your eyes in Mockingjay part 1
when Katniss could not shut the [ __ ] up
about saving Peeta he left Peeta and you
should have saved Peeta now cringes is
character evolves from a liability who
almost gets people killed to a liability
who actively kills people who no one in
the entire franchise can shut the [ __ ]
up about it's hard to see PETA this way
that's not Peeta saw Peter if Peter
didn't kill her own arrogance did it was
Peter that she wanted rescued from the
arena you saw Peter didn't you and Peter
along
it's from Peeta it's for Peeta hey Peter
yeah
isn't it obvious the next move is to
kill me man
even Peters over Peeta after four long
years waiting for the epic final chapter
of The Hunger Games watch it limp to the
finish line in an underwhelming
conclusion featuring reading letters
maybe the country's shocked night by
your arrow but once again I was not now
I'm loving every moment my son
reminds me every day of his father
Katniss
screaming at a cat and adding insult to
injury
Katniss actually choosing Peeta over
Gale kept by him I mean come on you're
choosing Cake Boss over a Hemsworth I
mean sure he was maybe responsible for
bombing and killing your sister but look
at this kiss man that's what I'm talking
about now look at how you kiss Peeta
look at me
now let's say that Gayle smooch again in
slow motion
see now that's how I would do it I mean
you know if I were Katniss Gayle is a
total hunk asaurus rex that any guy I
mean any girl would be totally lucky to
make out with are they putting the Peeta
on a pedestal
I would totally choose Gayle I mean you
know fire Katniss said ah screw it
gales hot and I would make out with that
face in a heartbeat starring Katniss
ever done with these movies Malory
Archer a waste of a perfectly good two G
teenage foggy Nelson turtle 3d printed
killer powders more captain phasma than
in Star Wars Peeta
let's see pan and we've done that one
already we're really running out of
jokes for the same cast guys hey Mitch
you're done with these movies that one
isn't great Gale of Oprah's friend you
know what they didn't put any effort
into ending this franchise so neither
will we
it's a little tedious after all these
years you said it girl
Mach yeah King yeah Jay yeah part two
uh I am so over these movies for movies
and the only actual choice Katniss makes
is saving her sister in the first one at
least that worked out
oh never mind be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers
do you dare Mock the son of a shepherd
der plant the stefarr has read camino is
blue you were my brother Anakin I loved
you it's called a hustle sweetheart
alright I've run out of patience
underoos time to make the chimi who
changes